Hello 大家好，我是斯文。这里是郭克斯文败类。
今天呢，我要聊一个我一直想聊，但是不太敢聊的话题，就是关于声域。
到现在为止，我们家多的宝宝已经一岁了，但是我一直不太敢，或者是不太能够非常顺畅的谈论声域这个话题。
但是我看到很多朋友回过留言说，你什么时候可以聊聊声域？
各位不想听声域话题的朋友们，我非常非常理解大家对这件事情的底触和无感。
还有一些朋友看到留言说，本来没有打算声域，但是好像到了一定的年纪，会有一些外界的压力。
因为你确实到了一定的阶段，你的身体就不太允许你在做声域这件事情了。
所以说女生可能到了35岁左右的时候，就会觉得头顶上悬着一把刀，
就是好像说我要不要去做这件事情。
所以说我会觉得谈论这样的话题可能会让大家比较的反感，或者觉得跟自己没有关系。
所以我会之前一直比较害怕谈论这个话题。
我其实以前也是一个完全没有想过自己会声誉的人，可能我从小我妈对我的一些言传深教，
因为我妈是那个剖腹产，我从小跟我妈去洗澡的时候就看见我妈那个肚皮像西瓜皮一样，
就是非常的花，全是那个很严重的认身纹。你想1980年剖腹产的技术其实是非常不成熟的。
它是那种竖剖，从肚起眼到它的那个下体部分，是一道非常深的伤疤，
因为它当时比较胖，它那个伤疤你知道像那个人的屁股一样，就那个伤疤是往里面陷了，
然后两边的肉像那个屁股一样会凸出来。
其实理论上我妈长得应该是挺好看的，但是我每次看到它的裸体的时候，
我都觉得它的肚子这部分其实是，它自己会感到有一些羞耻，我能感受到它的这个东西。
我在想我妈当时生我的时候才22岁，那个年代大家生孩子普遍比较早嘛。
然后我现在回想起22岁，实际是现在的大学生，本科生刚毕业的一个年纪。
它在这么年轻的一个年纪，就因为生孩子，就是让自己的身材遭受了如此之大的一个创伤。
另外一点，就是你生育之前，我觉得很多女生都是那种过得很开心，很纯真，
生活中也有很多可以去享乐的事情，
但是生育之后似乎所有的妈妈都变成了那种狠心如苦，非常操心，不但非常操心。
而且好像你的这种操心还非常的被嫌弃，你会活成一个非常喜欢念念叨叨，
然后喜欢抱怨，喜欢诉苦，又不太愿意去自己享受，
只能把所有好东西都给别人，差的东西都留给自己。
就是所谓的妈味，我觉得就像之前刘阿姨一样，我每次回宝季她就说，
你回来了，我们去买点那个一号土猪肉，我就觉得好像我不回来她就不配吃那个一号土猪肉一样。
我觉得我妈这方面还是做的比较不错的，就是她一直挺会自己享受自己的人生的。
但我觉得大部分的妈妈都是没有办法像这样子生活，
所以好像你生了孩子之后你就会完全的丢掉自我，
我觉得这件事情可以令我非常的恐惧。
所以说我以前其实是没有想过要生孩子的，
而且我觉得到我们这一代人的时候，所谓的养儿房老这件事情根本就不存在。
你的孩子只要不是很老，你就是万幸，
就是你怎么能指望她去给你的养老提供保障呢？
那到底生孩子她有什么好处？
对我来说，她除了毁掉我的身材，占用我的精力，
给我带来很多的生活和经济负担之外，
那她能给我带来什么东西？
你说她是可爱，那我觉得我养一个小猫小狗也很可爱。
那她到底还能带给我什么？
我其实在25岁的时候，因为那个时候我的月经非常非常不准，
我当时月经总是推后，有时候是推后10天，有时候推迟半个月，
直到有一天我的月经推迟三个月，我就去医院检查，
然后那个医生就让我查什么，我还记得叫磁机素六项，
还有一个什么东西，反正就是抽血检查，
还做了那个什么B超之类的，
检查出来她说我是多囊卵巢综合症，
说我的这个情况还是蛮严重的，
我说那会有什么后果呢，
就因为我觉得我的生活也没有带来什么影响，
她说你就是容易长斗，容易那个毛发比较旺盛，
我心想这也不会怎样，长斗就长斗呗，
然后她说你这个最大的问题是会造成不孕不育，
我当时听到这个就很像那个电视剧里的情节，
仿佛一个很严重的宣判，
但是我当时心里面居然有一次窃息，
我在想哇，太好了，我也不会意外怀孕，
我也不用承受这样的伤害，
但是我在想我此时不应该难过一下吗，
但我为什么一点都没有难过，
然后我当时的男朋友，
因为我俩当时是异地吗，
然后我就打电话跟她讲，
我说我今天去医院说我是多囊卵巢综合症，
然后我当时想看她的反应，
因为她是一个非常传统的人，
我觉得，然后她就说哎，那就算了吧，
我就感觉她的那种语气中带着一丝似乎是对我的仁慈，
虽然你是一个这样有缺陷的女人，
但我依然接纳你，你看我是不是很厉害，
我就觉得很奇怪，
我没有做什么值得被宽恕的事情，
但是她怎么就宽恕我了，
然后我觉得这种心态其实是很微妙的，
所以那个时候我其实是非常断定，
我这辈子是不会有孩子的，
所以我的脑子里面就压根儿没有考虑过这件事情，
然后我觉得哇，我的生活更加自由了，
好像不管有没有做措施我都不会怀孕，
当然我还是在做措施，
但是我觉得你这个措施也是就是一个形同虚设，
得知我自己怀孕那一刻我是很震惊的，
我跟现在的伴侣其实在一起的时候没有聊过，
他可能会有时候提一句，
他说你会想过生孩子吗？
他是这样的语气说，
他还不会说我不要生孩子，
他说你有没有考虑，
曾经考虑过生孩子这件事情，
我说没有，
他说哦，
他说嗯，那也挺好的，就这样，
所以我觉得他是完全尊重我的一个状态，
这也是我们能够最后走到一起的一个前提，
我觉得我这个人的人生就让你奇怪，
我觉得老天就会一直给我布置功课，
所以当时在怀孕之前，
我觉得哇，天哪，
我的人生也过得太开心了吧，
我当时的工作就是播客，
然后我觉得录播客也太轻松了，
然后每天身体也这么好，
然后睡眠也很好，
然后我再想，
哎呀,
这个也是有一点点的经济基础，
想去哪旅游，
就可以去哪旅游，
然后我觉得也太开心了吧，
然后突然之间，
我就发现我怀孕了，
我记得那个时候，
我就开始印药很频繁，
我当时其实很担心，
我一直渗不太好，
我当时想，
哇，完了，
我的肾本来我觉得已经还OK了，
已经恢复健康了，
但怎么突然开始就一眼尿频多，
然后我想完了，
可能我的肾又不行了，
我就很焦虑这件事情，
当时觉得其实特别的沮丧，
我养生这么多年，
功亏已亏，
到底是为什么呀？
不知道发生了什么，
让我的身体突然这么糟糕，
我都没有怀孕过，
我会怀孕，
后来我发现，
别人抽那个二手烟的味道，
我极其的敏感，
就是嗅觉会放大很多，
我有一次去我小书家，
他就是一个特别喜欢抽烟的人，
我发现我在房间里面，
看书我记得是，
然后我小时候在客厅，
他们家很大，
200多坪,
其实是非常非常大的一个房子，
我在一个房间里把门关上，
他在客厅抽了一根烟，
我一下就闻到了，
我当时想，
天呐,
我在想我的嗅觉，
怎么扩大了100倍，
然后我再想，
我不会怀孕了吧，
我就脑子里面突然闪过一个念头，
然后我吓一跳，
然后我就立刻去买了一个那个，
那个市值，
我一册，
真的怀孕了，
我当时就五雷轰艇，
我觉得天呐，
就是为什么命运可以过这样的惩罚，
我就很害怕，
当时就非常的紧张，
非常的无错，
然后非常的茫然，
就是觉得，
哇,
就是我不知道如何去面对这件事情，
然后我也不知道如何去，
面对一个要成为一个母亲的人生，
我当时第一念头是，
我要不要去做人工流产，
还去查了就是做人流的最佳时间，
应该是这个怀孕几周，
我就害怕错过那个最佳时间，
我那天晚上应该是一晚上没睡觉觉，
我在想这东西到底应该如何抉择，
然后我在想，
我之前一个不孕不育的人，
如此之高龄的情况下，
怎么就突然怀孕了，
因为其实在佛家的理论里面讲，
就是成为一个生命是非常非常不容易的，
他需要经历千难万险，
他才能够就是成为一个人，
然后我当然觉得天呐，
就是我也不要剥夺别人，
想成为一个人的权利，
而且在此之前，
我还去录了一个宗义，
我在那个宗义上，
因为当时那个地特别滑，
然后我一屁股从那个凳子掉下来了，
然后我当时就觉得很搞笑，很滑稽，
但是我后来想想，
那个时候其实是最容易流产的时候，
但是他居然也自己流存了下来，
那我觉得这个小生命应该是非常顽强，
以及他非常想留在这个世界上的，
所以我觉得，
我应该帮助他去完成他的生命的这个职责吧，
然后我想算了，
既然这是天意，
那我就咬牙接受这个上天的，
我也不知道是亏证还是考验，
然后当时我老公说，
他说你想要吗，
他说你要不想要就不要了，没关系，
我说我不知道，
他说那你想清楚，
他说因为这个事情，
是需要你自己承担很多的责任的，
他说所以说，
你要是决定要我们就要，
你要决定不要我们就不要，
就这样，
我发现了很多影视剧里面，
说大家有孩子的时候是很喜悦，
但是当时我一点喜悦都感受不到，
感受到了只有恐慌，
但是我觉得这个东西怎么说呢，
我当时的心情，
特别像我要去参加高考一样，
就这件事情虽然对我来说很可怕，
但是它是我的任务，
就是我必须要去做，
你知道有个词，
我当时特别反感，
叫害喜，
电视上每次那个你看那个孕妇，
嘔吐啊什么的，
大家都说你看他害喜了，
然后整个那个电视觉得氛围，
就是非常的欢乐，
然后大家都让他幸福，
然后我当时也觉得，
这个就不就嘔吐一下吗，
也没什么，
就是看着挺喜庆的，
但是实际上你在亲身经历这个，
所谓的害喜这个过程的时候，
是非常难受了，
这个感觉就好像你生了一场，
旷日持久的胃病，
整天就是一个病人的状态，
就是我在想，
如果我非常期待这个小生命的诞生的话，
我此刻应该会带着幸福的心情去，
经历这些，
我甚至会觉得这些都是他，
在成长过程中的一些，
小小的里程碑，对吧，
我当时的心情就是我完全，
没有想过要一个孩子的时候，
这是一个责任，
是一个任务的情况下，
我就会觉得这每一个过程都很难熬，
就是在我想要嘔吐的时候，
吃不下饭的时候，
觉得我很难带着一种，
期待和一种幸福的心情去，
经历和体会这一切，
我觉得我第一次清清楚楚的感受到，
我跟男性的区别，
就是作为一个人类，
就是女性跟男性真切的区别，
就是你真的有一个子宫，
我当时甚至觉得我的子宫在被使用，
就是为什么这件事情这么艰难，
就必须由我来完成，
为什么对方就是如此潇洒自在，
然后什么都不用去经历，
什么痛苦都不用感受，
他就可以无痛当罢呢，
然后我对这件事情，
其实半路中是有很大的怨恨的，
然后我就经常跟我老公说，
我说你为什么这么不小心呢？
他说我已经很小心了，
我说你就是不小心才会这样，
就是我会有很多的这种愤怒在，
很这种埋怨在，
然后怀孕的过程中，
除了这个嘔吐之外，
其实还有很多的难受的部分，
我就感觉在掰着指头数日子，
我就想哎呀，
到了三个月的时候会不会好一点，
然后我就想胡说茶，
说三个月的时候会怎么怎么样，
怎么想，就是脏气，
我就想脏气是什么东西，
当天晚上我就脏气了，
我就发现我根本没有办法睡觉，
就是已经两三点了，
但是我躺在床上，
我就一直很想打个，
打不出来，
我就必须做起来，
做起来之后很长时间，
我才能打出一个个，
然后才能舒服个一秒钟，
又继续第二次脏气，
所以我发现我每个月都会经历那种，
网上那种教科书式的那种孕妇的反应，
然后每次经历这些反应，
我觉得天哪，
这样的日子到底什么时候才能结束，
这样的考验到底什么时候才能完成，
所以我都是不停的看小红书，
因为小红书，
我觉得对于怀孕的孕妇朋友非常友好，
因为大家都会分享自己的体验，
比如说四个月就会太冻了吧，
我其实记不太清了，
但是当时我就在想，
哎，我什么时候会太冻，
就是好像有一群人。
跟你在同样经历的状况下，
大家互相分享着彼此的感受，
然后有时候你会有一些遭遇，
我还会用我的小孩去留言，
姐妹，现在你好点了吗？
然后那个博主就会回复，
哎呀，现在好多了，
我就觉得人生充满希望，
再过一个月就好多了，
所以我在怀孕的时候，
每天都在查小红书，
然后我觉得到了怀孕第七个月的时候，
我其实已经非常紧张了，
因为大家都说，
到了第七个月会非常难过，
然后我想象也是，
因为当时肚子已经很大了，
但是我唯一比较自豪的地方，
就是没有长认身闻，
因为我那个油涂的就很好，
还有一个就是我发现，
怀孕的时候，
大家都以为是一个负重，
只是肚子大了，
包括我看了很多那个博主，
他们会怀着运去卢铁，
还有人怀着运去，
什么引体向上，
因为我还是在怀孕之前，
有一个运动习惯的人，
我当时就在，
天呐，我怀孕的时候也要这样，
就是我过两个月我就要这样，
然后发现根本就不行，
就是你完全没有力气，
它不是一个负重的问题，
就它不是说一个健康人，
带了一个十斤的一个肚子在那儿做运动，
不是这种感觉，
它完全是好像
把你的那个整个气血都抽干的感觉，
就你像一个那种重感冒犯者，
然后再带着一个十斤的肚子，
然后这个情况，
你看你说你去做运动，
我觉得这件事情极其的不现实，
所以我以前发现一个很简单的一个行为，
比如逛超市，
这是一个以前非常不起眼的日常，
但是此刻对我来说很艰难，
还有一个就是当时那个腿也会肿，
我记得我是从27周开始，
以前呢你就觉得那个腿走在路上，
它是分开的，
然后那个腿一肿呢，
你会觉得那个腿，
那个肉都并在一起了，
互相磨擦的感觉，
脚吧也开始肿，
只能穿那种很大的脱鞋，
这样子的话就会造成人举步为奸，
而且我想要买机票，
我想要出去旅游一圈，
我发现我根本没有办法自己去旅游，
其实在家是很闷的，
因为你每天只能去周边的几个地方，
然后吃家里面自己做的饭，
然后每天好像我只能去一下我家附近的公园，
去一下超市，
然后有时候就会坐车去一下什么江边，
走两步，
走两步你就没有力气了，
然后腿就开始肿，
然后我就只能转个十分钟，
我就回家就这样子，
所以当时觉得天呐，
就是我就跟那个坐牢的时候放风一样，
今天放风可以去超市转五分钟，
转一会就不行了，
要就疼得不行，
然后就赶紧回家，就这样子。
虽然刚刚我讲了很多怀孕的一些负面感受，
但是接下来我要讲一个最负面的，
刚刚的我觉得都不够负面，
我觉得其实对我来讲，
怀孕最可怕的一件事情，
是让我的脑子改变了，
就是我以前觉得即便我的身体不好，
但起码我还有一个清晰的大脑，
我可以思考很多事情，
我可以跟朋友聊天，
我可以有非常流畅的表达，
这样的话我的内心就不会那么的封闭和痛苦，
但是我发现怀孕之后，
你的脑子真的会结构性的改变，
第一个很重要的表现，
就是你的记忆力会非常的差，
因为我之前我觉得我是一个记忆力很好的人，
我记得当时跟鲁鱼老师聊那个眼中花树的时候，
他就说，
我就问他你觉得摔老最大的体现是什么，
他说摔老最大的体现是我的记性很差，
他说他以前是一个记忆力非常好的人，
大家众所周知啊，
但是他有一天突然发现自己记忆很差的时候就很沮丧，
我当时还没有这种体会，
我觉得我以前就很多事情就会过目不忘，
就是一下子在我面前发生了，
我觉得他所有细节都会历历在目，
但是我发现怀孕之后，
很多事情我想要去讲，
想要去转述，
我发现我调动不出来的记忆了，
我觉得这种感觉非常可怕，
还有一个就是我发现，
当时我在录播课的时候有一种非常陌生的感觉，
就是我发现我居然讲了上句，
想不起下句，
我从来没有这样的感觉，
然后那段时间我非常难过，
就是我在想难道这件事情，
让我连我人生中最自豪的一项技能都丧失了吗？
所以我在想好像我的外表被剥夺，
我的身体被剥夺，
我的记忆被剥夺，
连我的语言也被剥夺，
你就不知道自己的人生到底还剩下什么，
你也不知道这些东西以后还会不会恢复，
不知道自己发胖的身体还会否恢复到以前的状态，
不知道自己的记忆力还能否像以前一样，
其实有很多据说是孕妇才能体会到的幸福感，
比如说胎动，
就你知道我看那个什么玫瑰的故事，
黄一眉坐在公交车上感受太多，
突然幸福那个感觉，
我非常期待我是不是也能感受到一次幸福，
结果胎动的时候你知道第一次胎动是什么感觉，
第一次胎动的时候我还以为是我的肠子在入洞，
要放了个屁，
我就觉得我的肠子里面有一股气体在洞来洞去，
然后我在想我是不是要放屁了，
结果半天也没放，
我就查孕妇为什么会有放屁的感觉而不放屁，
结果有人说这其实是胎动，
我们想啊这就是胎动，
后来这种胎动的感觉就是慢慢的越来越明显，
然后我就感觉到当那个宝宝她在你的肚子里面。
越来越成型，
越来越大肢的时候，
其实有时候你是可以摸到她的那个小胳膊小腿的，
就是你会摸到一个硬硬的一个东西，
然后她就在那动来动去，
我当时就觉得这种感觉很奇怪，
我不是觉得幸福，
我是觉得奇怪，
就是有另外一个人在你的身体里面动来动去，
你又跟她很熟，
你又跟她很陌生，
你又不知道她是谁，
就是这种感觉，
然后我当时一直很自我谴责，
我就会觉得说完了，
我才想我这个人是不是一点母爱都没有，
就是人家有态动，怎么都那么幸福，
我为什么会觉得毫无感觉，
甚至会觉得非常的诡异，
后来我就发现怀孕的时候，
其实你的情绪是非常不稳定的，
我当时其实分不清这个情绪不稳定，
是来自于各方各面的这种苦闷，
还是来自于激素的一个波动，
我其实分不清楚的，
因为就是心情很差，
非常想找人发泄，
我看见我老公，
我就会觉得不爽，
我就会觉得就是你，
让我来到了今天这个处境，
就非常生气，
就莫名的生气，
然后我当时还，
就是问了我的一个大学同学，
因为我觉得她是一个。
情绪极其稳定的一个女生，
她还是已经10岁了，
我就问她，
我说你怀孕的时候，
会不会心情很差，
她说会，心情非常差，
她说我以前还抓我老公的脸，
然后她最后就让我抓，
她说我觉得这是男人能起到的唯一作用，
然后我说，
嗯，也是，
因为你的这种身体上的，
这种痛苦和负担，
就是对方是没有，
任何她可以分担的，
但是我觉得她唯一可以分担的，
就是在我情绪很差的时候，
她可以忍受一下，
我觉得她大部分时候，
还是能接住我的情绪，
但有时候我觉得我太做了，
就实在是，
太难受了，
你就觉得你这种难受，
实在是，
就跟这个人有完全的责任，
然后我就会很生气，
我就，我记得有一次，
我都不知道为什么生气，
就是反正两个人大吵一架，
就她当时可能也真的受够了，
因为前面我太做了，
然后做到有一天，
她实在是人无可忍，
然后有一天就开始跟她吵架，
她就跟我吵了几句，
因为她以前都是不反驳的，
然后那天终于反驳了几句，
我说你居然反驳我，
我说你都没有子公可以生孩子，
你居然还敢反驳我，
你好夸张，好过分啊，
我说你能做什么，
我说你现在什么都做不了，
你唯一能做的就是，
就是帮我分担情绪，
你连这个都不做了吗，
当时我记得，
晚上都快12点了，
七八个月了，
肚子已经很大了，
我就光光光就往楼下走，
她就很担心，
就急忙追下来，
然后我就一直跑一跑，
跑到我们家楼，
旁边的那个，
一楼的那个门洞，
进去之后有一个，
小小的一个，
没有什么人，
用的那种储藏间一样的地方，
然后我就躲到那个里面，
就坐在那个台阶上，
然后我就看她在外面，
一直找一直找，
然后那个时候我就躲在里面，
我突然觉得这是一个很静密的空间，
我可以在这里坐一下，
然后当时也很晚，
外面没有什么人，
结果突然之间，
我就发现，
有一个身影，
捏手捏脚都走了进来，
是一只流浪猫，
然后那个流浪猫，
他一走进来之后，
我俩眼睛对视的那一刻，
他吓得跳了起来，
然后我也吓得跳了一下，
我俩都把鼻子吓到了，
然后当时我就，
非常有顾虑，
我就特别害怕，
因为人家都说，
就是你运气的情绪，
会非常影响到这个，
宝宝的情绪的发展，
给他的未来的一些情绪状态，
就是很多人都说，
啊，你怀孕的时候，
一定要情绪稳定，
一定要保持美好的心情，
我当时觉得，
说这些话的人，
真的很不要脸，
就是,
谁能在这样的状态下，
保持美好的心情，
你每天拖着一个，
如此笨重，
而痛苦的身体，
然后你每天，
哪儿也不能去，
什么也不能干，
这怎么能保持，
一个美好的心情，
还是激素还在这里，
让你不停地发飙，
这种感觉，
你一边，
就是情绪很不稳定，
另外一方面，
会担心自己，
这个不稳定的情绪，
会危害肚子里的，
孩子的未来的一些，
什么神经系统之类的，
所以我就当时，
就是很难受，
就是你又不能这样，
又不能那样，
然后如果你的，
这些情绪，
如果自己被自己，
强压下来，
你的心里，
就会很难受，很憋屈啊，
我觉得，
这也是一个很难受的感觉，
然后你要发现出来，
你会怕影响他的情绪，
我真的不知道，
到底应该怎么办，
然后我看那个，
网上很多的，
怀孕的那个女生，
就说,
我刚刚到那个孩子，
足月的时候，
就用剖副产的方式，
给她生出来，
因为这样的话，
就不用忍受怀孕的痛苦了，
然后很多人说，
不行啊，
一定要到39个月，
就让她要足月，
她才能健康，
我当时就在想，
为什么只能她健康，
不能我健康，
但是后来，
我觉得还是算了吧，
完事一至此，
也不差这两周了，
所以后来，
我其实是，
非常想要，
顺产的，
然后,
我一直跟医生说，
我说我能不能顺产，
医生说，
哎呀,
我现在的年纪已经很大了，
太儿其实不小，
因为当时我们家，
宝宝生出来的时候，
有6.5斤,
就是我只有1米5几的一个身高，
然后医生说，
她说这个体重的孩子，
对你来说，
已经是你的极限了，
我当时非常想顺产，
就是因为我想到，
我妈肚子上那条疤，
就是我觉得肚子上有疤，
是一件，
非常让我害怕，
或者说，
难受的事情，
我希望我生完之后，
肚皮还是光溜溜的，
我就会觉得，
这件事情对我的，
损伤小一些，
但是最后因为，
到了39周的时候，
我就检查，
是那个有点，
洋水浑浊，
就是必须得抛，
所以还最后，
还是做了抛肤产，
我在抛肤产的前夜，
我一晚上没睡着觉，
明天的话，
我的肚子上，
就会流一刁，
下辈子永久，
都去不掉的上巴，
结果第二天去，
进手出室的时候，
我当时不是，
带着那个血压移吗，
我就看到那个，
血压移的那个指数，
大概有，
178,
就是很高的血压，
然后那个医生在旁边说，
你怎么紧张到这个程度，
我就想，
谁会不紧张啊，
怎么会不紧张啊，
我一个躺在，
手术台上的人，
然后我的肚子，
即将被拉开，
怎么会不紧张呢，
但是对于医生来说，
他可能每天都要，
做无数遍这样的事情，
他可能觉得，
司空见惯，
我被推进手术室的时候，
就听见旁边的那个，
手术室里面，
有那种婴儿的哭声，
那个哭声非常的戏剧，
我以前以为，
每个小孩的哭声，
都不一样，
我觉得很神奇，
因为我当时是那个，
办麻嘛，
他就是，
先给你打一个，
小小的，
就是表皮的麻醉，
然后再拿一个，
很粗的针管，
给你打那个，
挤住的那个麻醉，
我麻醉之后，
其实你是可以听到，
他们在讲话的，
你也可以听到，
他们在说什么，
我就能感受到，
肚子上被拉了一下，
但是没有痛感啊，
只是你能感受到，
一个很重的一个，
触感,
所以我能感受到，
有很多人在压我的肚子，
我当时就想吐，
哇，很难受当时，
那个肚子很大，
但是在做手术的时候，
你就必须得平躺，
然后我发现，
我根本就喘不上气，
我就说，
什么时候可以结束，
然后医生说，快了，快了，快了，
他说，这是最后一刻，
最后一刻，
这是最难受的时候，
他说，最难受的时候，
真的很难受，
就是几个人，
压着你的肚子，
然后就好像，
把你的肚子，
给拽掉的那种感觉，
突然之间，
他就被拽出来了，
拽出来之后，
我就听见，
像刚刚那个，
教科书般的哭声，
oh my god,。
这是谁呀，
我觉得这件事情，
让我觉得非常的神奇，
然后也很怪，
我没有办法，
在那一刻，
认领他是我的孩子，
我甚至也没有办法接受，
我已经是一个，
有孩子的人的，
这么一种身份，
那个护士就把他，
报过来说，
你看，男孩女孩，
我说，男孩，
男孩,
然后他就说，
你看,
只有这一个，
什么小小胎记，
然后我就被拽出去，
拽出去之后，
我就上了那个纸痛蹦，
我就昏睡了三天三夜，
中间会给我换药啊，
会给我什么，
换什么针，
我都,
没有什么意识，
偶尔醒的那个瞬间，
会听到那个小孩在哭，
但那个时候，
我也不觉得，
是我的小孩，
脑子里面知道，
但我觉得，
我跟他没有任何的关系，
然后后来那个护士，
把他放到我的身边，
他说，来妈妈贴一贴，
然后我看了一点，
我甚至就，
就没有力气，
转头,
就是亲戚的看到他，
我只是觉得，
有一个，
有一个那种小婴儿，
然后他好小啊，
然后,
令人发指，
他那个手，
好像只有我的那个，
食指和大拇指，
就是还一圈的，
这么一个大小，
我一看那个手，
天呐,
就很像一个微雕，
就这么小的一个手，
居然还能分成五个手指，
我觉得好神奇啊，
我在生他之前，
就是他在出生之前，
就每次产检都特别担心，
他有什么问题，
因为当时，
我去做产检的一个医院，
是不负责检查那个，
五个手指头，
和五个脚指头的，
我就非常担心，
他生出来，
因为五个手指头怎么办，
然后我就仔细地看，
哦，五个，
然后我就放心地睡了过去，
而且我后来觉得，
他出生之后，
我老公其实还是，
我以前跟他讲，
我说我都生了他，
我说那是不是你应该来带他，
我觉得那个时候，
我对带孩子，
还没有任何的概念，
我心中的带孩子，
可能就跟养个猫差不多，
我觉得他应该可以，
自己喝奶吧，
就把奶给他，
他就自己喝了，
然后他就自己睡觉呗，
不就给他买卖奶粉，
买卖尿布，
给他换一下不就好了吗，
我心中的带孩子，
而且我觉得我老公很神气的，
就是我觉得我要成为一个妈妈，
这件事情对我来说，
需要很多的过渡和自我认同，
但我觉得他好像完全没有这样的过程，
他好像就很自然说，
哎，过来爸爸抱一抱，
不然我觉得，
哎，这个人，
怎么如此轻盈自然地接受这件事情，
然后我觉得这可能也是我跟他，
能够组成一个家庭的原因，
他跟我是很不一样的人，
就是我们俩还挺互补的，
他是一个非常稳定和轻盈的人，
然后我说，那我生出来之后，
你来带哦，
他说好，没问题，就这样，
他也对带孩子没有任何概念，
我发现，
我当时以为他能够承担带孩子的这个任务，
不用我操心，
但我后来发现不可能，
我发现这是一个生理性的问题，
妈妈对孩子的这个痛苦，
和他的需求的先天感知，
就是会远远超越爸爸，
甚至远远超越任何人，
我觉得这个任何人都没有办法，
跟妈妈此时对孩子的那个，
需求的敏感和补助，
相提并论，
我看过一篇文章说有一个科学研究，
就是说女性在怀孕之后，
他的大脑结构就会发生一些改变，
关于思考问题和逻辑的思维的这个部分，
就会减少，
而他就是关注孩子需求的那部分，
就会增加，
所以说我发现，
生完孩子之后，
他淡淡有一个哭声，
我就会飞奔过去，
查看他到底怎么了，
然后他饿了，
他渴了，
然后他要拉了什么的，
有时候就是别人都发现不了，
就是只有你能发现这件事情，
比如说我们家孩子，
他的那个太阳穴，
就是他剩下来那个头型，
你知道小孩剩下来的头型，
他都是那种，
他头是软的，
然后我发现他有一天，
他那个太阳穴，
是凹陷的，
然后我就查，
这个太阳穴凹陷是怎么回事，
然后很多人说，
这个是因为小孩的头型没有睡好，
然后我再想，
原来还有睡头型，
但是我发现除了我之外，
没有人关注他太阳穴凹陷这件事情，
也没有人关注他的头型，
当时我们家宝宝已经四个多月了，
就是他再不睡头型的话，
他就已经，
因为六个月，
他的头就已经定型了，
我就想，天哪，
只有两个月给我了，
因为当时所有人都没有提过这个问题，
然后我就顿时从网上。
买了五个枕头，
就是一个一个给他试，
后来就发现，
其中有一个枕头，
是对他比较适配的，
那两个月，
就是从四个月到六个月，
我就非常担心他的头型，
后来到了第五个月的时候，
他的头型已经睡得明显，
就好转了很多，
我就发现，
哦，他的照片已经跟以前不一样，
太阳血已经没有那么凹陷了，
哎，我就觉得很欣慰，
然后每天我就看他的那个，
那个太阳血两边，
就是不对秤，你知道吗，
然后有一天发现，
哎，左边这个稍微凹陷一点，
右边稍微好一点，
我说，好，
从现在开始就给他，
就给他睡他左边的这部分，
然后睡着睡着，
哦，发现两边对秤了，
然后他头型终于定型了，
我想，天哪，
就是我的一个，
心头大患终于解决了，
妈妈会关心你的方方面面，
所以我想起以前一个朋友，
小时候有一次我记得，
我们在一块喝茶聊天的时候，
当时他就说，
他说，其实每一个人，
你人生中的第一幕记忆，
是奠定了你这辈子的人生祭调的，
第一幕记忆是痛苦的，
那你这辈子可能会过得比较坎坷，
但你如果第一幕记忆是非常快乐的，
可能你这辈子都非常的幸福快乐，
当时我们就在，
回溯自己的这辈子的第一幕记忆，
因为我和他都是那种比较忧郁的人，
我就说我第一幕记忆是，
大概两三岁的时候，
跟我妈去洗澡，
去那个公公澡堂洗澡，
我就从那个台阶上有两三级，
我就摔得下来了，
然后就滚了个跟头，
然后就滚得我很疼，
哎，我说难怪我这辈子这么坎坷，
然后他太坎的，
就那个朋友他太坎在旁边说，
他说，嗯，
他说我第一幕记忆好像是，
大概五六岁的时候，
他说跟我爸妈妈去街上吃西瓜，
当我记得那个西瓜就很好吃，
他们就买了一家西瓜给我吃，
哎，就很甜，很开心，
然后我俩就感慨说，
难怪你这辈子这么开心，
这么幸福，
我每天都这么阳光，
然后有我那个朋友，
我说，那你第一幕记忆是什么？
他说我第一幕记忆是我两岁的时候，
我妈妈的葬礼，
我当时真的觉得好心痛，
然后我看他那个样子，
他已经很平静，
他讲述这一幕的时候，
他是很平淡的，
在我有了孩子之后，
我真的觉得，
一个两岁的孩子，
看到自己妈妈的葬礼，
是一种什么感觉，
就是这个世界上，
可能再也没有人，
像妈妈那样心疼他了，
后来他就说，
他奶奶带他，
然后他奶奶也有别的事情，
还要干农活什么的，
他奶奶就把他绑在一个椅子上，
就是让他不要到处乱跑，
会有危险，
他已经是一个快50岁的人了，
他到现在他都记得，
他被绑在那个椅子上，
动态不了，
然后有很痛苦的感觉，
所以他就非常讨厌，
被束缚在一个什么地方，
哇，我当时真的很心痛，
然后他就说，
他说我小时候非常讨厌一首歌，
就是《市场只有妈妈好》，
这些人就唱《市场只有妈妈好》，
就算了，
有妈的孩子算个宝一，
他说还非要再加一句，
没妈的孩子像根草，
他说你们幸福你们的，
为什么非要引摄我呢，
我以前其实知道他妈妈在，
很早年就去设，
但是我从来没有像那天，
那么真切地感受到他的痛苦，
好像你当了妈妈之后，
你就会天然的共情，
很多很多人，
因为你会知道，
每一个人他小时候，
就是这么脆弱的一个宝宝，
他都有这么无助的时刻，
我看网上的留言说，
我当妈妈了看不得这个，
就是你没有当妈妈的时候，
你可能还没有感受过一个人，
在如此无助的时候，
他的那种状态和心情，
但你当妈妈了，
你就知道一个婴儿，
他是多么的娇弱，
他是多么的需要别人照顾，
如果没有人照顾，
他真的会死亡，
然后他如果没有爱，
他如果没有妈妈，
他会是一个
真的没有人管的一个孩子，
他就是命运随波主流，
可能别人不管怎么伤害他，
他也没有能力反抗，
这是一个非常非常悲伤的事情，
所以说，
我觉得就是在我们家宝宝出生之后，
就是每次我看到他需要照顾。
和需要别人去关注情绪的时候，
我觉得那种母爱可能是自然的，
我就会极其地共情他，
而且有时候，
我觉得我已经过度共情了，
因为我觉得我小时候，
经常会一个人面对一个寂寞的空间，
可能那个空间只有我一个人，
我就会觉得非常非常孤独，
所以我非常害怕我们家。
多多会有面对孤独的时刻，
所以每次他只要一个人，
如果他发现他的面前没有人，
他就会非常的恐慌，
就开始哭了，
然后他这样哭，
我就非常心痛，
我就会觉得天呐，
他此刻面前是没有人的，
他觉得是孤独的，
所以我就会冲过去，
就是立刻说慢慢在，慢慢在，
不要害怕慢慢在，
我就会不停地跟他重复这句话，
我也不知道他三四个月的时候，
是不是能听懂我在说什么，
我就觉得好像我只要一次没有回应他，
他就会留下难以磨灭的心灵创伤，
但我后来发现我看了一篇文章，
就是一个科学家说，
他说其实孩子要经历过。
很多很多次这样的无人回应的境地，
他才会形成一个比较严重的心灵创伤，
就是偶尔其实是没有关系的，
所以我发现那一刻，
我的那种过渡反应和焦虑，
其实源自于我自己的小时候的那种恐惧，
其实我是有一个比较代常和。
抚慰自己的一个动机吧，
我觉得这种母爱和他的这种连接，
可能就是这样一次一次，
就是从很心疼他，很害怕他受伤害，
很害怕他难过开始的，
我当时一直在听王妃给他的孩子写的歌，
就是我当时刚刚生完她的时候，
我就一直单曲循环那个童，
我觉得他写的太好了，
他写的那个词我以前都不太理解，
他说，我怕你不知道我是谁，
你让我慢慢体会，
就我在想，他怎么知道我是他的妈妈呢？
我如果不自我介绍，
如果这个世界上没有给他科普，
妈妈是一个什么样的角色，
他怎么能认出我是他的妈妈呢？
阿姨带他那个什么比较多，
他会不会觉得阿姨才是他最亲的人？
然后这个时候你有很矛盾，
你就觉得阿姨如果跟他很亲，
那说明阿姨把他带得很好，
但是阿姨如果跟他不亲，
就说明阿姨带他不好，
他也很黏，你就会觉得他是不是受到了什么伤害，
所以我觉得这个当妈妈的心真的好矛盾啊，
你又害怕别人跟他太亲，
你又害怕别人用他不亲，
所以当时我就在单曲循环，
然后包括王妃还有一首给那个斗镜筒写的歌，
就是那个你快乐，
所以我快乐，
就是他有一句子诗，
你没头开了，
你眼睛红了，
我的天灰了，
就是我发现我的所有情绪是跟着他走的，
就是他只要露出笑容，
我就会不由自主地绽放笑容，
他如果只要哭，
我就会心里面就是不由自主地，
就像手掌一下把你的心揪住一样这种感觉，
你是完全无法控制这种情绪的，
所以我觉得要说跟他这怎么守起来的，
我觉得可能是这种一次一次的这种情绪投入，
就是你跟他共情，
然后你去照顾他的一点一滴，
就是这样跟他守的吧，
我们家当时的那个月嫂阿姨，
当时后来我让他直接就转成月儿嫂了，
我觉得他是一个非常非常完美的一个妈妈的人选，
讲实话，
我觉得他当时因为我们家多多就是完全指认他不认我，
我一方面非常替他开心，
因为我觉得阿姨带他带得真的很好，
我有时候觉得他怎么这么幸运，
怎么有对他这么好的阿姨，
然后发阿姨也是一个非常浪漫的人，
就是他很懂孩子，
然后我记得有一次我们就抱那个宝宝去公园玩嘛，
旁边有个小朋友大概三四岁吧，一个小男孩，
骑了个那种小自行车，
然后就急急骑到我们面前，
就那样子停下来看着我们，
我在想这个小孩停下来看着我们，
是什么意思呢？
然后我们家那个范阿姨就说，
她说,
哦，你厉害，你厉害，你最厉害了，
真厉害，真厉害，
那小孩很开心，她就走了，
我说，哎，
我说你是为什么就这样夸他呢？
她说，她这样骑到你面前停下来，
就是让你夸她的呀？
我说，你是怎么看出来的？
她说，这很明显啊，
这一看就看出来，
我说，那我为什么看不出来的？
她说，啊？
她说，这很明显啊，
我说，你为什么这么懂小孩呢？
她说，我不知道呀，
我从小就是很懂这个小孩在想什么，
我说，哎？
我说，你怎么真的牛啊，
然后她有一次，
她就是抱着多多，
我们再过去吃饭，
在那个等电梯的那个空间里面，
然后多多就在那里就很兴奋，
就啊啊啊啊，
就一直啊啊啊，这种声音，
我说，你怎么了？
我说，你为什么一直在啊啊啊啊，
为什么在喊什么呀，
有什么需求啊？
然后那个翻爱就说，她说，
啊，她说，她觉得这个地方回音很大，
她觉得这样啊啊啊，
叫着很有意思，
我说，你是怎么知道她，
她会这样想的呢？
她说，这很明显啊，
这样啊啊啊，就有回音，
她就很开心啊，
我说，你太厉害了吧，
我说，你也太懂小孩了吧，
我经常觉得，
我跟着她俩那个，
很开心的样子，
我就很羡慕，
我就在想，哎呀，
我们家多多太幸福了，
同时我又，
我就在想，哎天哪，
如果翻爱意跟她这么亲，
她会不会更加不认识我是谁了，
因为我在旁边，
特别像一个第三者，
特别像一个配角，
然后我就觉得，
心情有那么一点点矛盾，
但是我当时在想，
没关系，就即便她不认识我是谁，
只要她过得幸福，
就只要有人真的爱她，
真的对她好，
我觉得我都OK，
我真的是这种感觉，
有一次我记得坐在车上，
然后我们家多多不放个屁，
然后翻爱意就，
嘿，这样笑了一下，
然后，哎，很奇怪，
就多到那个时候才，
五六个月，
她其实还不太懂怎么沟通，
然后翻爱意就，
嘿，笑了一下，
多多就，
就开始哼哼，
然后翻爱意就说，
她说,
没关系，多多啊，
阿姨不是在嘲笑你，
阿姨是笑你可爱，
笑你太可爱了，
然后多多就，
嗯,
我当时觉得好神奇，
就她们真的会交流，
她好像真的能听懂翻爱意，
她说什么，
而且翻爱意居然能，
如此精准的捕捉到她的情绪，
就是我不是在嘲笑你，
我不是在笑你可爱，
她居然真的就开心了，
哇，我当时觉得这个阿姨。
太厉害了吧，
就怎么会有这么厉害的人，
我说,
翻爱意，
你真的是一个天选妈妈，
我说,
你怎么这么会当妈妈，
你的孩子好幸福啊，
我说,
我为什么完全不会当妈妈，
其实我当时是有点沮丧，
就是我在想，
人家为什么能力这么强，
为什么一点能力都没有，
因为她其实年纪也不大，
她才83年，
比我大三岁，
她们家有三个孩子，
她最小的孩子才六岁，
但她就是，
因为为了赚钱嘛，
就是不得不被景理乡来上海，
当那个月早阿姨，
她听我说完之后，
她说,
宝妈啊，
你不要这样说，
她说,
哪有什么妈妈是完美的，
没有任何一个妈妈是完美的，
她说,
你觉得我很适合当妈妈，
但是,
她说,
我这么适合当妈妈，
我都没有办法，
陪在我孩子的身边，
我只能出来，
她说,
我的孩子怎么会觉得，
我是一个完美的妈妈，
她说,
而且,
我也没有什么，
给他们的未来，
做指导，
做什么托底的能力，
我其实很羡慕你，
她说,
我觉得你才是一个很好的妈妈，
你看你有能力，
你可以请那个，
阿姨来带孩子，
她说,
我都没有办法，
我只能，
拋起我的孩子，
去带别人的孩子，
我当时觉得，
好难过啊，
就是,
我觉得一个人，
他可能，
只有一份母爱，
然后这份母爱，
他给了别人的孩子，
自己的孩子就没有了，
他虽然是一个完美的妈妈，
但是完美的妈妈，
却不能陪在自己的孩子身边，
我觉得好难过，
然后果不其然，
到了多多，
可能,
七八个月的时候，
范阿姨就说，
她说,
她在上海太久了，
她要回家，
因为她要回去，
照看自己的孩子，
她们家老二，
要准备中考，
然后她有点抑郁症，
所以很焦虑，
很担心她，
所以一定要回去，
她其实很喜欢，
在上海工作，
她就觉得，
她上海很开心啊，
有很多，
好吃的好看的，
好玩的，
然后她说，
多多也很可爱，
她说,
我也很喜欢多多，
我就在那里跟多多互动的时候，
我就说，
啊,
我说那个没关系，
我说,
等阿姨回来之后，
我们去看阿姨，
好不好，
就这样，
然后范阿姨说，
哎呀,
她说,
我要回到上海的话，
我还需要你们来看我，
她说,
我把东西放下，
第一时间，
我就打车来看多多，
我就在旁边，
我眼泪就刷了一下，
留下来，
我就觉得很尴尬，
我也觉得，
哎,
很不好意思，
结果我就，
我就一直在那儿不动，
她说,
啊,
把那个多多抱过来，
给她洗澡了，
我就一直不好意思转过来，
我一转过来，
让她看到我泪流满面，
我觉得很丢脸，
然后我想，
算了,
反正这个眼泪，
受不回去，
然后我就转过去，
范阿姨看到我流泪，
她就说，
你别这样，
宝妈,
然后她就开始哭，
然后我俩就在那儿抱头痛哭，
然后范阿姨走的时候，
都会对我不高而别，
或者是对我欺骗，
然后我就跟范阿姨说，
我说,
你要走的时候，
你一定要跟多多好好的道别，
我说,
你不要，
就趁她很不注意的时候，
就溜走，
这样的话，
她肯定会接受不了的，
范阿姨说，
好的,
然后那天，
我还在想，
她什么时候会跟她道别，
然后她走的前一天，
她就跟我说，
宝妈,
我已经跟多多道别过了，
给我哭的心里哗来的，
然后她说，
多多好像没什么反应，
然后,
我在想，
啊,
渣男,
范阿姨跟她道别的，
但是她肯定是跟她很认真的，
讲了,
然后没想到范阿姨走的时候，
我就说，
多多,
范阿姨要走了，
我说,
你跟她拜拜好不好，
平时其实，
多多都不太要我的，
就是我要去抱她的时候，
她根本就，
不想被我抱，
她就是一直，
缩在那个范阿姨的怀里，
后来我发现，
范阿姨跟她道别之后，
她突然之间，
在范阿姨的怀里，
就要找我，
就她就过来，
就要找我抱，
我当时觉得，
这件事情怎么这么神奇啊，
就是我在想，
这个小小宝宝，
虽然才七八个月，
但她,
似乎真的知道所有的事情，
如果跟她认真的道别，
她真的会接受这个，
别理,
然后我觉得，
这可能是她人生第一次，
痛苦的分别，
但她就这么自然的过渡了，
然后我当时觉得，
天呐,
她真是一个很强大的生命，
所以我当时对她是很佩服的，
我在想，
如果是我的话，
我肯定，
没有办法这么顺利的，
接受这件事情，
就好了，
我觉得我其实很难，
找到像，
这样的阿姨了，
然后后面也，
后面也在找其他的阿姨，
我发现也是有个好处，
就是翻阿姨在的时候，
因为我，
我发现她太厉害了，
所以我，
我对于玉儿这件事情，
完全是一个空白，
后来那的阿姨，
好像都不那么厉害了，
就导致我必须得自己上手，
让我发现这事情，
也没有那么难，
后来我现在就变成了一个，
也可以自己带孩子的人，
多多也跟我熟了一些，
就当现在终于，
就是知道我是谁了，
然后我也不知道，
这个过程是怎么发生的，
但她,
她昨天，
就是,
人生第一次，
非常清楚地叫了，
一句妈妈，
我当时很惊讶，
她之前，
就是会无意识的那种，
她认识我，
她知道我是她那个熟人，
然后她昨天，
就是我在那里，
点一树香，
背对着她，
阿姨就领着她，
她就盘上的，
当当当走过来，
从后面抱着我的大腿，
因为我那个香，
还没有点完，
手里还有火，
所以我就，
没有第一时间回应她，
结果呢，
她就炖了一秒钟，
很清晰地说了一声，
妈妈,
我当时，
心里面有点惊呆，
我觉得我，
好像,
突然之间，
真正地认领了这个称号，
我突然觉得，
妈妈这个词，
是世界上，
最亲密的一种关系，
你已经认领了，
实际上，
跟你最亲密的人，
然后我也认领了，
一份更大的责任，
她叫我妈妈的时候，
我其实在心里面，
炖错了，
零点五秒，
然后我觉得我要，
第一时间回应她，
我就,
哎,
然后一撞过就是，
就这样，
给她一个，
一个回应，
然后她就那样，
笑嘻嘻的那样，
看着我，
我真的觉得，
跟一个，
非常之，
广控而纯净的，
灵魂链接上，
她会让我生命的那种，
宽度,
好像一下子，
扩大了很多，
好像我一下子，
能够,
领会,
更深刻的，
以及更加广貌的，
这种人类的情感，
所以我觉得，
这是一种，
礼物对我来讲，
这个过程，
很像什么呢，
很像那种，
就是攀灯，
猪风之类的东西，
就是你为了，
体力,
材力,
然后以及，
过人的意志力，
以及你会，
可能面临你，
根本都，
想象不到的危险，
但你可能，
灯到,
那个猪风，
灯顶的时候，
那一刻，
你只开心了那一刻，
但那一刻，
似乎,
会让你之前的这些，
攀灯,
都显得非常值得，
我记得，
当时有一个朋友，
他跟我讲说，
他说,
你现在是多多妈妈，
我说,
哇，好可怕，
这个名字，
你不要这样叫我，
他说没关系，
他说,
不管你谁，
都是多多妈妈，
到你在那个群里面，
称呼,
就是多多妈妈，
好像我一下子，
就埋没了自己的姓名，
但我现在发现，
我此刻，
我觉得我没有那么大的，
这种疑虑，
我只是觉得，
自己好像，
多了一份，
非常重要的工作，
这种感觉，
就好像我多了一个职位，
这个职位，
是多多妈妈，
我觉得我只要，
走出这个家门，
或者我不在，
多多身边的时候，
我就是我自己，
但是我有时候，
会有点自责，
我在想，
我这个人，
我是不是一个，
很不称职，
或者不敬责的，
一个妈妈，
我这么有自我，
不太对吧，
这种感觉，
我觉得可能，
每一个妈妈，
都会有这种，
自我谴责的时刻，
每一个妈妈，
都希望自己，
是一个，
非常完美的妈妈，
希望自己，
在方方面面，
都能够，
好好地照顾，
和保护自己的孩子，
但是没有妈妈，
是完美的，
如果你是，
有有工作的妈妈，
你可能就，
不会像一个，
全职的妈妈那样，
能够的，
去照顾她，
有工作的妈妈，
那样,
觉得自己，
对未来，
是有方向和把握的，
你可能会觉得，
因为这件事情，
也没有办法，
给孩子做到一个，
很好的表率，
或者很好的，
一个,
所谓的托举，
我跟范阿姨，
聊完之后，
突然觉得，
可能每一个妈妈，
都希望自己，
是完美的妈妈，
但是没有妈妈，
但是我们，
都已经，
是足够好的妈妈，
所以我突然觉得，
问心无愧，
我以前不知道，
这个妈妈，
来自何方，
分支抗拒的东西，
我特别害怕，
我这个人身上，
出现妈卫，
我后来发现，
这个妈卫，
是什么呢，
就是,
很多事情，
除了你，
没有人操心，
比如说以前，
我会想，
这个事情，
比如说这个小孩，
他又饿了，
没有人给他，
喂奶,
怎么办，
我以前就会想，
那就让他饿了，
如果他爸觉得，
他饿不下去，
他就自己喂了，
我就会这样，
想,
但是实际上，
很饿的时候，
等他哭，
就你根本就忍不下这个心，
既然你忍不下这个心，
那这个事情，
只能你来托地，
因为你是最看不下去，
这件事情的人，
所以你就变成，
做最多事情的人，
而且这些劳动，
是非常隐形的，
你操了这么多心，
你做了这么多事情，
就是你的这些工作，
别人淡淡，
用一点点的破坏，
或者不配合，
那你是不是会，
很气炸，对不对，
我就发现，
原来这个妈卫，
里面的烦躁，
和抱怨，
这种烙倒，
来源于这种东西，
所以说，
其实我以前，
非常非常害怕，
自己成为一个，
事无俱夕的操心，
然后别人，
一旦不剩我的意义，
就开始，
烙倒，抱怨，
和痛苦的一个，
一个妈妈，
就是很有妈卫的一个人，
而且,
我觉得以前，
就是,
当你很有少年感的时候，
或者是，
你不用为了，
任何事情负责任的时候，
你就可以随便的，
去解构很多东西，
但当你进入一个，
比如说当妈妈，
或者甚至是，
你是一个，
比如说，
团队领导的一个状态，
你就会不得不去，
建设很多东西，
就比如说，
组织一个公司年会，
或者是一个妈妈，
再计划一项旅行，
因为所有的东西，
都是你，
一针一线，
然后一钻一瓦，
气起来的，
你就会觉得，
这个事情，
让它成形如此之难，
而嘲笑它，
却如此之简单，
所以我现在，
真的很难，
嘲笑这些事情，
所以我现在觉得，
我一定是有些妈卫的，
但是我觉得，
同时也伴随这些，
责任,
当我,
学会为很多事情，
负责任的时候，
我觉得也意味着，
我的肩膀上，
多了一些担当，
当我能够去，
负责很多事情的时候，
我发现，
我也多了一些力量，
有妈卫证明，
我很厉害，
证明我可以，
做到很多妈妈，
该做的事情，
证明我很有力量，
所以我现在觉得，
我是一个，
很厉害的人，
我觉得这是对我的包装，
但是我觉得，
不生育，
也没什么关系，
这个就好像，
比如说，
然后每次，
我的朋友们，
很喜欢吃海鲜的朋友，
就会大点特点，
那个虾要卸，
然后他们就，
对我表示遗憾，
说，你太可怜了，
你连这么好吃的卸，
你都不能吃，
哇,
就是杨成功，
大家卸，
多么厉害，
你去,
哇,
太好吃了，
你居然一口都不能吃，
你太可怜了，
我现在想，
这有什么可怜，
我就吃过一次，
我也不怎么觉得好吃，
我一点都不觉得，
不能吃海鲜，
是一个遗憾，
因为我根本就不爱吃，
所以我觉得，
吃一份非常重要的体验，
而且我之前，
我记得，
跟一个朋友去，
听那个脱口秀，
因为那时候，
我还没有做脱口秀，
然后我都觉得，
那个脱口秀，
好难看，
一点都不好笑，
但我那个朋友，
就在那，
哈哈大笑，
我说,
你不是喜剧品味很厉害，
你为什么在这样的场合，
还能哈哈大笑，
他说,
你来都来了，
都说,
这个时间，
你就已经耗着了，
你不笑，
你在那儿，
捧个脸，
有什么乐趣呢，
孩子呢，
你还不如给他，
赋予一些，
正向跟欢乐的意义，
所以我记得，
以前我在那个，
脱口秀大会上说，
我说,
我过什么样的生活，
我就会美化什么样的生活，
我觉得，
既然你都过了，
你还不如，
想点他的好处，
你会过得开心一点，对吧，
好,
那我们今天关于，
生育的话题，
就到这里吧，
今天讲的，
其实是我真实的感受，
我记得我在，
知道怀孕之前，
我见了一个，
朋友和他的太太，
他们都是那种，
然后,
他们的孩子，
非常非常的好，
非常可爱，
非常优秀，
已经上大学了，
然后他们俩，
讲起那怀孩子的时候，
他们觉得是非常幸福的，
就是那个女生，
那个姐姐，
都说,
天呐,
怀孕的时候，
我觉得自己，
可神气了，
可开心，
可幸福了，
我在想，
这个世界上的，
每一个人，
可能他们都有不同的感受，
他们在怀孕的时候，
的心情，
和身体的状态，
都是不太一样的，
所以我今天讲的，
真实的一个分享，
然后也不代表，
所有人怀孕都这么痛苦，
所以说，
大家,
就是也不用听我一面之词，
如果你真的，
想要做一个，
生育的打算，
或者什么的话，
你可以多问问，
多一点的人，
因为每个人的体验，
都是非常不同的，
如果听到这里的朋友，
感谢大家的聆听，
如果不想听的朋友，
也感谢你的包容，
那我们今天就这样吧，
拜拜!